[Alkış]
Evet değerli
katılımcılar önce işin ekonomik yönünden
başlayayım Türkiye dünyanın 17 büyük
ekonomisi Bu ekonomik büyüklüğü
sürdürebilmek toplumsal gelişimi insani
gelişimi sağlamadan Acaba mümkün mü
eğitimde
dünyanın çok gerisindeyiz eğitim yılı
ortalamasına baktığınız zaman dünya
ortalamasının gerisindeyiz cinsiyet
eşitliği yok kadınlar toplumdan
dışlanmış gençler toplumdan dışlanmış
her şeyi 55 yaş üzeri erkeklerin
yönettiği yönlendirdiği bir toplum
noktasındayız sağlık harcamalarına bakın
ifade özgürlüğüne bakın Basın
özgürlüğüne bakın her şey bloke edilmiş
durumda yıllardır bu anlayış devam
ediyor Bunu yapmak acaba devletin
sorumluluğunda mı yoksa Bizler sivil
girişimler olarak bir şeyler yapabilir
miyiz
[Müzik]
Ben Pointer Çalışmıyor
galiba Ben bunun sivil girişim
daha Sürdürülebilir hale geleceğini
düşündüğüm için ben göstereyim mi
Nereden yapacaksınız bu
çalışmı Ben bunu Yıllar önce bu kaygıyı
profesyonel yaşamımda kurumsal yaşamda
gördüm işin temelinde tabii hepimizin
ortak buluştuğu nokta eğitim var Ancak
sivil girişimlerle bu işi
hareketlendirmenin önemli olduğunu
düşündüm ve 94 yılından başlayarak
eğitimden başlayarak bir takım
girişimlerim oldu önce Enka okullarının
hem İstanbul'da hem de adapazarıda
kuruculuğunu üstlendim sorumluluğunu
üstlendim hala devam ediyorum ardından
Türkiye Eğitim gönüleri Vakfının kuruluş
sorumluluğunu üstlendi
bir dönem Uzunca bir süre yönetim kurulu
başkanlığını yaptım Türkiye'de eğitim
alanında ciddi bir sivil hareket haline
geldi Mahalle afet Gönüllüleri 99
depreminden sonra mahallelerde gönüllü
örgütlenmeler olası bir afete karşı
girişim
başlatma teşebbüsü olarak girdi ve ondan
sonra 2002 yılında toplum gönüllerini
Eee önderliğini yaparak onu başlattık
toplum gönülleri Türkiye'nin gençlik
alanında en büyük sivil kuruluşu oldu o
zamanlar arkadaşlar benim yaşlarım beni
eleştirdiler dediler ki sen gençleri
örgütlü başın belaya
gce algı bu bugün itibariyle Türkiye'nin
en büyük gençlik kuruluşu olduu Biraz
sonra rakamları vereceğim vakayım öğret
Akademisi vakı türkiye'
öğret
eğitimler veren çok yaygın bir çalışma
yapan bugüne kadar 100 binden fazla
öğretmene bu mesleki gelişimleri verdik
bir kuruluş oldu aşoka
Türkiye aşoka dünyada en önemli sosyal
girişimcilik çalışmalarını yapan bir
kuruluş onun Türkiye vakfını kurduk onun
başkanıyım ve en sona Ali İsmail Korkmaz
Vakfının yönetim kurulunda görev aldım
ailesi onun hayallerini yaşatmak
amacıyla böyle bir vakıf kurdu benden de
parçası olmamı rica ettiler bunu da bir
Onur olarak kabul ettim orada da
çalışıyorum başım belaya girecek
dedikleri terör örgütü yaratacaksın
dedikleri gençlik kuruluşu bugün geldiği
nokta itibariyle Türkiye'nin en büyük
Gençlik Hareketi oldu Sadece 2014
yılında Burada da göreceğiniz üzerine
58.000 genç bir yılda 58.000 genç
513. insanın yaşamına dokunacak şekilde
14'e yakın toplum hizmeti projeleri köy
okullarına giderler çevre projeleri
yaparlar Sokak çocuklarınla çalışırlar
üreme sağlığı eğitimleri kararı gençler
verir yetişkinler onlara proje empoze
etmez gönüllülük anlayışımız Bu
doğrultuda bütün farklılıklarla bir
arada çalışmalar devam ediyor
hiçbir kuruma hiçbir holdinge hiçbir
aileye bağlı değiliz yaygın bir bağış
ağımız var kurulduğumuz bu yana ciddi
bir kaynak üretmiş Çünkü şeffaflık ve
hesap verebilirliği savunan bir ilkeyle
topluma sivil topluma örnek
oluyor Sadece Türkiye sınırlarına mı
kalacağız Bizler Sizler bu toplumda bir
azınlığı aslında
yani toplumun geneline baktığımız zaman
daha iyi eğitim imkanları olan daha iyi
sosyal imkanları olan insanlar bu
toplumun gelişmesinin ötesinde bu
dünyanın gelişimi için bir şeyler
yapmayacak
mıyız şu tablolar 1 milyar insanın aç
olduğu tablolar beni ciddi düşüncelere
sevk etti ve bir gün Afrika'dan Beni
ziyarete gelen randevu alıp ziyarete
gelen iki tane Afrikalı adamın
anlattıklarıyla O zaman ben bu dünyayı
değiştirebilmek için bir adım atmam
gerekir diye karar
verdim Ne yapabilirim sizin için diye
sorma benim tarzım değil ben sormuyorum
O soruları ben ne
yapabilirim ben de yapabilirim esas
atmamız gereken adım sen de yapabilirsin
hepimiz yapabiliriz Yeter ki
niyetlenen
[Müzik]
gambiya'nın
değil sosyal yaşamda Sürdürülebilir
projelere en az gelişmiş ülkelerden
başlayarak destek vermek Evet Evet
Gambiya Burası arkadaşlar
ve Afrika'nın en küçük
ülkesi daha
önce köle ticaretinin başladığı unt
kinta adasının orada olduğu Ondan sonra
İngiltere'den bağımsızlığını elde etmiş
ama nüfusunun yarısı yü 50'si açlık
sınırında yoksulluktan bahsetmiyorum
yoklukla cebelleş
Birleşmiş Milletler verilerine göre de
en alt sıralarda çocukların temel ölüm
nedenleri 5 yaşına gelmeden suya
erişemedi bizim için çok önemli olan
plastik şişen alıp gerisine attığımız su
Orada bir altın değerinde bir büyük
maden değerinde Ziyaret
ettiğim bakan Balıkçılık ve
hayvancılıktan sorumlu bakanın kapısında
şunu gördüm
bu dedim size mi özel yok dedi bu bizim
Kamuda çalışan herkesin kapısında yazar
çünkü dünyanın ve bizim İçinde
bulunduğumuz
gerçek yaşam ortamları Ben köylerde
yaşadım orada gittiğimde ailelerle
yaşadım böyle yıldızlı yıldızlı tek
yıldızlı otellerden bahsetmiyorum
yaşam yararlandığı tuvalet
sistemi ev diyemeyeceğim bir ortamda
insanların tuvalet sistemleri ortada
gördüğünüz kırmızı dairenin içindeki
kapak Bu bir komünitenin yararlandığı
mutfak Burası bir okul Burası bir okul
sınıfı Burada da çocuklar bu şekilde
oturup
tahtada tebeşir yok çakıl taşlarıyla
Eee ders çalışıyorlar Burası biraz daha
geliştirilmiş bir sınıf susuzluk çok en
temel insanlar kilometrelerce yürüyorlar
Bu bir yemek yeme modeli orada
gördüğünüz beyaz el bizim oradaki
gönüllü koordinatörümüz
elidir günde bir öğün pirinç yiyerek
besleniyorlar Bir deneyin bir a boyunca
günde sadece bir öğün pirinç yiyerek
bakalım Siz nasıl
hissedeceksiniz projeler geliştirdik
yerelin ihtiyaçlarını anlamadan yerelde
yerel bir kuruluşla işbirliği yapmadan
beyaz
adamın empoze edeceği projeler
doğrularıyla
ilerleyemez her yerelin her kültürün
kendi ihtiyaçları tercihleri farklı
oluyor o nedenle yerelde bir sivil
toplum kuruluşu
oralı bir kuruluşla işbirliği yapıyoruz
buradan bir gönüllümüz gidiyor en az 6
ay orada kalıyor
projeleri organize ediyor
gözetiyor Biz ortada Bu gördüğünüz alan
Gambiya ortada büyük bir nehir var ama
balık tutma olanakları yok çünkü balıkçı
tekneleri yok balık ağları yok biz 4
tane köye tane balıkçı teknesi balık ağı
verdik şart balıkların bir kısmı
balıkçılarda en az % isi köy halkına
dağıtılacak Dolayısıyla bütün köy halkı
beslenmeye katkı olacağı Dolayısıyla
sahiplendi Bunlar bizim verdiğimiz balık
i
tekmeleri balıklar Tabii Soğutma
Sistemleri olmadığı için çoğu yerde
Elektrik yok bu şekilde güneşte
kuruyorlar ve 18 ayda 18 ton balık
tutuldu en az 30 3000 kişinin
beslenmesine katkı sağlandı devam ediyor
bu
projemiz kadınların yükü çok
ağır başlarında yük sırtlarında doğal
yük çocuklar bir taraftan su alıyor Bir
taraftan taşıyor düşecekmiş gibi
korkuyorum bir sefer giderken çocuklara
oyuncak
götürdüm kızlara bebek erkeklere top
götürdüm
çok mutlu oldular bir hafta sonra bana
bir fotoğraf
geldi böyle bir
gülümsen
insanlar büyük mutlulukla
karşılıyorlar artık yapılan projeler
onların
potansiyellerini harekete geçirdiği için
canlandırdığı ve onlara güvenilerek
geliştirildiği için
onlar bize çok güvenmeye başladılar
ardından hayvancılık projesi başlattık
her aileye ik ila be tane küçükbaş
hayvan
veriyoruz 3 yıl boyunca kesmek yasak
doğacak her iki yavrudan bir
tanesini komşu aileye vermek
yükümlülüğünde Dolayısıyla bütün köy
halkı ikinci bana geliyor 4ün bana
geliyor diye projeyi sahiplendi
Eee ve
Biz 300 küçükbaş hayvanla başladığımız
projede bugün
2200 küçükbaş hayvana yaklaşmış
durumundayız 10 ana bölgede Eee
yararlanıcılar 900 aile bu projeden ve
Sürdürülebilir şekilde Çünkü orada
hayvancılık onlar için çok önemli bir
hayvanı sattıkları zaman oradan e 2
yıllık bir çocuğunun eğitim
gideri tavuk çiftlikleri başlattı her
köye 400 tane civciv veriyoruz E orada
kümes
yapıyoruz onları 3 ay sonra satıyorlar
ve bir kısmını geriye ödüyorlar biz
onlarla yeni çiftlikler kuruyoruz bir
kısmında da kendileri yararlanıyorlar
bugüne kadar 20 yerde kurduk bu tavuk
çiftliklerini Bunlar da aile için çok
mutluluk
veriyor Bu bakışlar tabii Ç etkiliyor
balık çiftlikleri kurduk balık
çiftlerimiz 7 tane balık Çiftliği pirinç
tarlalarını korumak için setler kurduk
Bu bir kadının eli Çünkü o pirinçleri
öğüterek
havanda dövere ellerini nır tutuyor köye
pirinç değirmeni verdik Bu pirinç
değirmenleri onları bütün köy halkının
yararlanma fırsatını
[Müzik]
tanıdı her yerde farklı bir
mutlulukla bunları dile
Getiriyorlar en temel sorun
Susuzluk bir yudum su orada şişeyle
dolaşırken yüzüme bakan
çocuklara döndüğümde hiç fütursuzca
yaklaşarak bir idum suyu içmenin
mutluluğunu görüyorlar O nedenle 26 köye
su kuyusu yaptık su kuyuları Çok önemli
çünkü çok fazla Bostan potansiyeli var
Burada gördüğünüz alanlarda soğan
yetiştiriyorlar çevrede çitler vahşi
hayvanların girmesini engelleyemediği
için domates
yetiştiremiyor ve gördüğünüz gibi
bunları sulay abilmek için işte oradan
elleriyle büyük bir enerjiyle su çekmeye
çalışıyorlar ve o hayvanlar da girmesin
diye sabah saat 4'ten gece saat 12 kadar
nöbet
tutuyorlar buna benzer tamirler su
kuyuları tamir ettirdik çok mutlu
oldular çocuk ölümleri azaldı Mar
marangozluk atölyesi eğitimleri
veriyoruz Güneş panelli Soğutma
Sistemleri Ama şu hikayeyi bir dinleyin
ve bundan suyu Ellen çekerek çıkartmak
çok zahmetli O nedenle kuyuya kovayı
gönderiyorlar ucunu da Ata bağlıyorlar
Şimdi at onu çekecek bak at nereye kadar
gidecek o zaman su kuyudan çıkmış olacak
bak çekilen suyun miktarı 10 kilo 12
kiloluk bir kovadan bahsediyoruz
arkadaşlar
gidiyor bir 10 kiloluk su Yöntem Bu
Çünkü Elektrik yok çünkü pompa
sistemleri ne yazık ki pek çok yerde yok
alternatifi Şimdi burada
göreceksiniz aynı miktarda büyük bir
bidon suyu şimdi kadınlar oradan elle
çekecekler 34 metreymiş 30
[Müzik]
metreden çaba çalışma
şe gündemimizde diğer projeler var
şimdi güneş enerjisiyle çalışan
sistemler kurmaya
çalışıyoruz ama çocuklar her koşulda çok
mutlu gayet Doğal ortam
içinde orada çamurdan bir topla
oynuyorlar köy yönetimlerine devrettik
bazı projeleri artık bu yıla yaklaştığı
için sadece onlar yönetimlerine
bakıyoruz raporlamaları alıyoruz 410.000
dolarla 200.000 insanın yaşamına
dokunmuş durumdayız yani kişi başı 2
dolar bütün bu Demin anlattığım
malzemelerin alımı harcadığımız
paralar bütün hesaplarımız uluslararası
bağımsız denetim şirket tarafından
denetleniyor gönüllü olarak Dolayısıyla
şeffaf ve hesap verebiliriz hidi idari
giderimiz yok Her şey amaca yönelik
kullanılıyor şimdi hedefimiz üye
sayımızı
çoğaltmak ve ikinci ülke Senegal'e adım
attık orada şimdi Bir Kuyu yapımı
başlattık insanlar çocuklar çok Mutlular
suya kavuşacakları için ikinci ülkemiz
orası Eee üyelik zaten broşürler imiz de
var Arzu edenler broşürleri de
okuyabilirler orada üye formlar ımız da
var girmek
isterseniz katkılarınız önerileriniz
çevreye yaygınlaştıran da sadece
Türkiye'de değil dünyada bir fark
yaratmanın mümkün olduğunu düşünüyoruz
tek amaç şu kızın bakışlarına bir unut
katabilmek
teşekkür
ederim
y